June is national Safety month and
Southwest Gas joins us to talk about how
we can all stay safe during these summer
months and joining us now is Steve
Miller the public information officer at
Southwest Gas welcome thank you very
much for having me it is the first day
of summer a lot of people are spending
time outside barbecuing digging doing
all sorts of stuff and thankfully we
have you as Southwest Gas to help keep
us safe talk about what Southwest Gas
does and their commitment to the safety
of the people here at blase is
absolutely as you mentioned it is
national Safety month but the safety and
sustainability of our communities our
customers our employees that's something
we do year round so we take that very
very seriously we have programs to help
help educate our customers our
contractors you know damage prevention
programs you know public awareness such
as call 8-1-1 before you dig those types
of things help keep our community safe
no you I'm glad you mentioned that
program because a lot of people are
going to be
all 8-1-1 just before your whole project
starts how does that work exactly sure
you call 8-1-1 uh two days at least two
working days before you put a shovel in
the ground okay and then we'll come out
we'll mark all of the underground
utilities because it's not just natural
gas there are you know power lines under
there there are sewer lines water and if
you damage those lines you could cause
an outage you could affect your entire
neighborhood that's really great that we
have that program and let's say you did
not call 8-1-1 and you start digging and
you smell something that's that's what
you got to be aware of and what is that
smell that we're looking for so it's a
sulfur rotten egg smell so I think it's
very obviously distinct
um if you smell that even just for a
moment or if you hear a hissing sound
coming from the ground or from your
meter or if you're looking and you see a
puddle of water that's bubbling or dirt
blowing in the air those are all signs
of a potential natural gas leak and what
you want to do is get out of the area
immediately leave the area and once you
get to a safe location you call 9-1-1
and Southwest Gas now let's say
exposing my family to that same thing
you call then same thing leave your
house but do not use your electric
garage door do not turn on any light
switches don't start your car or turn
off your car you want to leave
everything as is and just get in the
area get away from the area and and call
9-1-1 in Southwest Gas these are hurtful
and tips I never would have even thought
about doing something like that now if
you are unsure even if it's maybe like
spoiled food is that going to be a
problem if we still call and ask for
someone to come out call no matter what
we will come out and we'll investigate
it
um obviously we'd prefer that it is a
rotten food or something along those
lines but always call and we will come
out if you you think you suspect a
natural gas leak a better say
information how do they get it on safety
when it comes to Southwest absolutely go
to swgas.com safety we've got a whole
bunch of tips there and we just want
everybody to be safe I just learned so
much thank you so much and thank you
Southwest Gas for sponsoring this
segment give them a call at
877-860-6020 or visit their website
swgas.com
all right Mercedes